anyway the good news is the winds have
calmed down but now we're going to start
getting pretty hot as we get into the
weekend so you got to protect yourself
stay hydrated and get that sunscreen on
and just pace yourself out in the heat
of the day beautiful skies this morning
something that i do want you to put on
your calendar for the weekend is in the
nice evening hours it will be warm but
you protect yourself you don't need
special glasses to see a lunar eclipse
and this is in the evening hours the
moon rise 7 31 on sunday evening this is
sunday the beautiful full flower moon
and then by 8 30 you'll start to really
see the totality of the eclipse and
that's when the earth's shadow will be
cast across our across the moon and
you'll see it as a reddish color because
all of the the red light from our
sunrises and sunsets will be refracted
across the moon and then it turns a
reddish color really should be pretty
and then it should be over in about an
hour and a half and get back to its
beautiful white self a full moon for the
rest of the night so just something that
you might want to plan on maybe take the
kids out there to watch it
lots of 50s around the valley this
morning still 60s downtown 46 out at red
rock 41 at kyle county we're just not
dealing with all those crazy ferocious
winds that we've had most of the week
and for weeks now through the spring
months of 49 in mesquite 46 in indian
springs 49 in prep got 59 in searchlight
64 in laughlin and 52 in kingman it's
easy driving wherever you're going in
any direction if you're headed out of
town
we're going to stay dry the winds have
calmed down quite a bit and we'll just
look for light winds and more heat as we
get into the weekend the pacific
northwest getting another system cool
with some scattered showers up there 66
for the mountain light winds and jumping
into the 70s by tomorrow 90 out at the
lake be careful because you know those
north and south canyons can always get
some puffs of wind 89 for the valley
today yesterday
we were in the mid to upper 70s so quite
a jump and i've been warning you that
each day we're going to leap up into
some hotter temperatures tomorrow the
upper 90s and we are still looking for
100 degrees on sunday and right around
100 into the middle of next week then
breezy gusty winds at the end of the
week and that will bring temperatures
back down to the 80s by friday